with season five you guys found your
home in Philadelphia how would you say
Philly and the vibe of that place really
convinced Lynch the season wait let me
just say this Morgan you look gorgeous
like right like what what a lovely
vision you are and I will say silly was
credible
I'd never been I did Bobby a comeback
for you'd said you'd been before but I
never be but it was interesting because
it's a different piece from our our
seasons before we'd start then with
Georgia so southern hospitality we've
moved over to Kansas through the season
3 and season 4 and they were very easy
to crack whereas really they're our
community and we don't say that with it
with to denigrate at all it's just it
was a tougher it was a tougher sell
because they thought they really feel
like they know themselves and so to be
able to encourage them to open up and
let us in was thinking the payoff was
greater well it's very obvious to us how
you change lives of so many people you
work with a variety of people love the
first episode with Noah the gay pastor
who's just such an emotional episode we
see how you change their lives but how
do they impact your life you know what I
think there's a lot of times people
don't really realize that our heroes
aren't just the ones going through
change we are as well that there have
been it's getting a little easier the
new episode was a little easier for me
than the Bobby camp was in season one
and the mom and Tammy episode in season
two like mom and Tammy really helped me
work through some of those that
animosity that I had to wear to church
so by the time we got to know I was much
my heart was much more open as clearly
you know I was willing to actually go
into the church so yeah it's we we go
through a lot of emotions as well and
often you guys don't see that because
you know the cameras don't follow us
home when we go home and cry ourselves
to sleep but yeah it sometimes can be
very hard but I I love it because it
helps us grow and it helps us kind of
put ourselves in the shoes of the heroes
which we're asking to open up and to
grow themselves and if we are
like to do that then whether you know we
have no right to ask them to attend how
does it feel knowing that you're able to
bring so much confidence to so many
people like that's you guys doing that
it's honestly it main perk of the job is
known that you have such an impact on
somebody's life you can take somebody
who wouldn't even look at themselves in
the mirror let alone looking at
themselves in a negative way in the
mirror and then know that by the time
you leave they can hold a head up high
and with everybody in that community
they can say look at me I am worthy of
your love and your attention and the
Equality that you know that you are for
everybody else and that is a beautiful
feeling I have we've all suffered in our
lives with low self-esteem and variable
confidence and thankfully us fiber in a
position now where we are we feel what
we can offer the world don't don't get
wrong we don't feel confident every day
I think that is impossible but we know
our Spence we know what we offer our
community we know we are for our heroes
and to be able to pass that on to some
people feels really special so a lot of
people are at home right now a lot of
people have embraced the PJs track pants
they're posting about on social media
that's why I was so shocked by well
you've got on so what advice would you
have to elevate our at-home looks right
now but I would say is very simply this
if you look in the mirror and see a
version of yourself that you don't like
that you don't recognize that is
something wrong we can control very
little right now there's so much going
on in the world that we have zero
control over and so to just have this
one thing we get up out of bed in the
morning you look at yourself in the
mirror
you get to decide how you view yourself
and that makes like really powerful
you